THE STATE OF AI:
In January of 2023, Microsoft announced that
they would be investing $10 billion into OpenAI,
the parent company of ChatGPT.
It’s been over an year since that day and
OpenAI is now reporting that they’ve only
received a fraction of the promised $10 billion.
This isn’t to say that Microsoft won't follow
through with their full investment.
After all, $10 billion is just a drop in the
bucket for a $2.5 trillion giant like Microsoft.
But, it’s also clear that Microsoft isn’t
exactly jumping up and down to pour more funding
into OpenAI.
In fact, from the very beginning, Microsoft
structured the investment in tranches that
would need to be unlocked over a long period
of time.
And reading between the lines, it seems that
tensions between OpenAI and Microsoft are
more than just financial.
In November, for example, Microsoft was forced
to take a non voting position on the OpenAI
board despite owning 49% of the company.
And with the whole Sam Altman fiasco, Microsoft
may even have legitimate reason to completely
back out of the deal, and that’s just the
most notable AI drama.
It turns out that these sort of fallouts are
happening across the board throughout the
AI world as VCs pull back on funding AI projects
with ridiculous valuations.
I mean, just think about this.
OpenAI was looking to raise at a valuation
of $90 billion and the company barely pulls
in $1 billion in revenue per year.
Not to mention, Sam Altman himself has admitted
that OpenAI will need a $100 billion not in
valuation, but in just funding to fully develop
generative intelligence.
And all of this has been during a time in
which ChatGPT has been slowly bleeding users
month after month.
None of this is to say that AI is not the
future because it obviously is, but it does
seem like the AI industry very much got ahead
of itself, and VCs are starting to pull the
plug.
Just recently for example, a $4 billion AI
health startup named Olive, went under.
And Olive is simply one of a growing list
of unicorns turned zombies.
So, here’s the rise and fall of the AI hype
and what’s next for the AI industry.
A TUMULTUOUS INDUSTRY:
All burgeoning industries go through boom
and bust cycles.
That’s just how new innovations and tech
is created.
You have these massive bursts of enthusiasm
and excitement followed by a harsh reality
check before true mainstream adoption begins.
That’s exactly what happened with all the
dotcom companies in the early 2000s.
After years of unlimited funding, the vast
majority of dotcom companies ended up going
under never to be heard of again.
It was only after this cleansing that internet
companies like Amazon, Google, and Facebook
were really able to cement themselves for
the long term.
In most industries, this sort of cycle takes
maybe 20 to 30 years, but the same cannot
be said about the AI industry.
In fact, AI has been repeating this cycle
over and over again since the 1950s which
brings us back to the father of modern computing:
Alan Turing.
In 1950, Turing would publish a landmark research
paper called “Computing Machinery and Intelligence”.
In the paper, he explores the idea of whether
computers can think for which he offerd a
very simple answer.
If a computer is able to engage in conversation
with a human without the human noticing that
they’re talking to a computer, then, the
machine can indeed think.
He dubbed this test the imitation game and
this is what would eventually become the famous
Turing Test.
Inspired by these ideas, hundreds of scientists
would begin working on their own AI projects
hoping to pass the Turing Test.
This included more simple applications like
a checkers bot in 1952 but it also included
generative AI.
In fact, generative AI itself is by no means
a new invention.
As far back as the 1960s, we’ve seen scientists
grapple with the concept of language models
and chatbots.
The ELIZA chatbot for example attempted to
simulate the work of a psychotherapist way
back in 1961.
Scientists were even working on the groundwork
for self driving vehicles.
In the 1970s, for example, the Stanford cart
was able to navigate itself through room filled
with obstacles.
It seemed like AI was truly the next big thing?
But, do you know what happened after these
breakthroughs?
The first AI winter.
Funding for AI startups was wiped out as investors
realized that it was a lot more profitable
to invest in chip and computer companies with
strong revenue potential as opposed to these
theoretical projects.
And that’s exactly what they did.
After they made a crap ton of money with companies
like Sun Microsystems, Intel, Microsoft, Sony,
and Panasonic they would come back to the
speculation table.
Japan, for example, would commit $850 million
to what they called the fifth generation computer
project.
And IBM would begin work on next generation
AI called Deep Blue.
The goal was to create a chess bot that was
better than the world had ever seen.
This was by no means an easy task but in 1997,
IBM would do it.
Deep Blue would decisively beat the chess
world champion at the time: Garry Kasparov.
Once again, it seemed like AI was truly the
next big thing.
Not only was AI able to outsmart an average
joe but a world champion.
This was definitive proof that AI could do
great things.
But, after that, we would enter yet another
AI winter.
With investors losing money hand over fist
during the dotcom bust, the last thing they
wanted to do was speculate on AI projects
with no revenue potential.
That was until they got rich again thanks
to web companies like Google, Facebook, Amazon,
Uber, AirBnB and so on bringing us into the
current cycle.
As you can see, for 70 years now, AI has consistently
been this sort of elusive next big thing that’s
almost within grasp but not quite.
So, will this time be any different?
Well, at some point, it does have to be different.
That’s kind of how AI eventually becomes
mainstream.
But, judging by history, there’s no guarantee
that this cycle is the cycle.
That’s what people have been thinking for
the past 70 years only to be proven wrong
over and over again which brings us into the
question of why?
THE AI PITFALLS:
One of the biggest themes surrounding each
and every one of these AI winters is funding.
The reality is that AI is an extremely expensive
game, and it’s only getting more and more
expensive each cycle.
OpenAI for example is having to pay $1 million
per year to get access to the right engineers.
Not to mention the massive data centers and
loads of GPUs they need to make the entire
operation possible.
This is why Sam Altman thinks they need $100
billion.
But, all of that is only half the story because
AI is a doubled edged sword.
Not only does it take a stupid amount of money
to bring to market but it usually has very
little revenue potential atleast in its original
state.
It often has be evolved substantially before
being able to generate serious revenue.
As such, investors are only willing to take
this gamble when times are good.
When their other investments are doing well,
when the tech industry as a whole is booming,
and when they don’t know where else to invest
their money.
This was exactly what was happening throughout
the early 2020s.
Investors had hit it big with web companies
and unicorns, and with 0% interest rates,
they simply did not know where to put all
those profits, so they put it into AI.
But when the music stops playing as was the
case in the 1970s, the early 2000s, and right
now, they’re quick to cut losses and move
back to safety.
But, even putting the whole financing of AI
aside, it seems that the industry is always
stopped by a consistent internal factors themselves.
For example, limited computing power.
Even in the modern day where we have enough
computing power for basically any task imaginable,
somehow, we don’t have enough computing
power for AI.
And the main reason for this is that our needs
for AI are also constantly evolving.
Before we were just trying to create AIs that
could hold conversation or excel at a board
game.
Today, we’re trying to create AIs that can
not only hold conversation but scour the entire
web to answer our questions.
Similarly, we’re no longer trying to create
carts that can navigate a room within 5 hours
but cars that can navigate any road live.
Our demands of AI are rising exponentially
and as such, the resources needed to make
these projects a reality are also rising exponentially.
But even regardless of how many resources
we have, it’s usually only a matter of time
until we run into Moravec’s Paradox which
describes the odd disparity between human
and computer intellgience.
It turns out that doing things that are super
hard for humans like mass data analysis and
calculations are super easy for computers.
However, doing things that are easy for humans
like sensing depth, fine motor skills, and
innately leveraging feedback control systems
are near impossible.
And if all of those challenges were not hard
enough to overcome themselves, well, we have
yet to discuss the biggest challenge which
is the rise of AI phonies.
THE AI PHONIES:
With any hot trend, it’s only a matter of
time until the opportunists step into the
scene.
In crypto for example, for every bitcoin and
ethereum, there’s 100s of trash coins, rug
pulls, NFT projects, and straight up scams.
It’s the same thing with the AI space, just
in a more sophisticated manner.
For every OpenAI or Tesla FSD type effort,
you’ve got dozens garbage startups.
Most of them have nothing to do with AI whatsoever
or they barely leverage AI, but they’ll
put it all over their marketing and brand
themselves as an AI company.
In reality, they’re just a construction
or consulting firm.
But all of a sudden, they're an AI based construction
firm or an AI based consulting firm.
From an outside perspective, these are obviously
trash companies that way overstating their
use of AI.
But for desperate VCs who missed out on investing
in OpenAI, this truly seems like the future.
Sure, they might’ve missed out on bringing
AI to search or cars, but they can still be
the ones to bring it to the sewer industry
or the energy industry even though the application
is far more limited.
Fortuantely, this BS doesn’t go one forever,
but the fall of these zombie companies is
by no means graceful.
Usually, what happens is investors pull back
on all kinds of AI investing and only the
good companies end up surviving the funding
cut which is exactly what’s happening right
now.
Global VC funding has plummeted from $170
billion in the 4th quarter of 2021 to $70
billion in the 3rd quarter of 2023.
AI was one of the few sectors that was holding
up through this funding collapse, but we’re
starting to see cracks within the AI world
as well.
In Q3 of 2023, for example, the number of
AI VC deals shrunk by 27%.
Technically, the total value of these deals
increased by 39% to $6.1 billion, but $4 billion
of that was just due to one investment from
Amazon.
And you could say the same thing about all
of 2023 actually.
The main reason that the AI industry has held
up as well as it did was simply due to a handful
of massive deals from companies like Microsoft,
Nvidia, Google, Salesforce, and Amazon.
When we take these flagship deals out of the
picture though, the outlook for rest of the
AI industry becomes quite bleak, and that
brings us into the question of what happens
next?
Well, most likely another AI winter filled
with bankruptcies.
The flagship companies like OpenAI will most
likely survive but you probably won't hear
nearly as much about them on the news as much
as they enter a new phase of research and
development away from the public light.
That isn’t to say that this cycle was useless
though.
Another intrinsically cyclical sector is the
chip industry.
They have booms and busts basically every
decade or even multiple times per decade.
But, just because the industry is volatile
doesn't mean that they’re not making forward
progress.
Chips today are not even comparable to chips
from the 1950s, and it’s the same thing
with AI.
Historically, it’s simply been a highly
volatile industry, and we’re currently going
from a high to low, but eventually, the industry
will see the other side once again.
Do you think AI is overhyped?
Comment that down below.
Another industry that’s going through a
massive reality check is big tech, check out
this video to learn more.